as stevens group america first legal
marshal is the best conservative legal
minds
the state of texas is not is already
taking matters into their own hands
again the lone star state is suing the
biden administration for refusing
to take custody of illegal alien
criminals
that the state's legal brief stating
this defendants have issued and
implemented on lawful agency memoranda
that allow criminal aliens already
convicted of felony offenses to roam
free
in the united states doesn't feel good
as an american knowing that's happening
texas lieutenant governor dan patrick
here to expand on it
it's a shame lieutenant governor it's
come to this what is the next
legal moment for you did you file this
brief already
so the attorney general has filed the
brief and brian
the mayhem continues the mayhem
so this lawsuit is about the fact that
if we have someone in jail
who is an illegal alien and they've
already been convicted of a crime when
trump was president
we could call ice ice would come they'd
put a detainer on take them and deport
them today
biden says ice can't come and pick them
up so we either have to let them out on
the street or keep them in jail our
taxpayer
expense and have overcrowded jails the
president of the united states is
breaking the law
and then tonight brian we just sent the
texas rangers in this is new news
to the facility in san antonio because
we got complaints to state agencies
that there's no supervision because they
don't have enough people there they
can't get volunteers
there's sexual assault going on between
these teenagers in this
this is the the call that we got today
several calls they're not being fed
properly
they have kids with cove that aren't
being separated the president and the
vice president of the united states and
the democratic party are so concerned
about placating the left for open
borders children
are allegedly being sexually assaulted
on american soil because of
their their total neglect
on protecting our border protecting this
country and protecting these kids
whether they're dropped over the fence
whether
they're sexually assaulted whether
they're sent into the country into sex
trafficking joe biden and kamala harris
have this on their hands brian
they have this on their hands they're
letting criminals go in america and
they're putting kids at risk
that are coming across this border
illegally it must stop now
and we're in there investigating it and
if they won't do it
texas will last week we
saw pictures because republican senators
refused to delete their phones who took
pictures inside the donna facility
there were more horrendous pictures
there than a couple of pictures that
were taken
during which time it was president
obama's day when they said kids were in
cages
there wasn't the uproar but there was a
lot of angst and consternation
and they still can't handle it and i
think the news that you just broke is
this that the freeman coliseum facility
that the governor was talking about
today yes yes it it is at that
facility and what you have brian
is a total lack of law and order on the
border
there is no border security and we will
see
a million people potentially apprehended
just in texas meaning another million to
two million got through that we didn't
apprehend
you are seeing these children brought to
this country we have no idea where to
send them
know what to do with them they need to
close the border they need to go back to
the trump policies
because right if any children die the
blood is on the hands of the president
and the vice president because they're
allowing this to happen
by turning their back on the border she
doesn't even have the respect
for human beings for children to come to
the border and see it firsthand
it's unbelievable the president's
indifferent works two hours a day let me
talk about something else everyone
thinks it's georgia
and there's problem with delta airlines
you have a problem because america has a
problem with the new
texas rules as it goes to securing texas
elections
american airlines is rebuking the texas
voting bill
which is going to become law what's your
answer to american airlines who has a
problem with you and is headquartered in
dallas
yeah so get this we passed senate bill 7
out which is not about
voter suppression see the left has
changed voter suppression
they're replacing voter security with
that term we passed a strong
bill that's voter security we haven't
changed anything we still have
two weeks of early voting we're
expanding hours that people can vote
everything that's being said is an
absolute lie by the left
but american airlines had the audacity
to call my office last week and talk to
my chief of staff and say we just want
to let you know
that this isn't personal against the
lieutenant governor or the governor
but we're coming out against senate bill
seven and
they then said now we haven't read the
bill and my chief of staff said well how
about the ceo is he read the bill no he
hasn't read the bill
so the nerve of american airlines like
these other corporations
as dan crenshaw my good friend said
earlier coming in and getting their
nose in politics that they don't even
take the courtesy
and time to read a bill and so i do take
it personally
i take it personally on behalf of the 18
senators who voted
republicans who voted this out and the
governor supports
because when they talk about voter
suppression you know what they're really
talking about well there must be racism
there you're trying to keep people of
color down
i'm so sick and america is sick brian of
every issue
it's border republicans for or against
an issue well it's racism uh how we got
out the
vaccinations racism education health
care every issue
is racism it has to stop it's divisive
it's hurting this country
and we're going to pass this bill and
we'll have strong support right
this bill to have voter security in
texas uh the governor and you dan with
your broadcasting background you
certainly can make a point and uh
american airlines gonna have their hands
full
uh read the bill same thing with delta
airlines read the bill you know what
you're talking about major league
baseball you embarrassed yourself
you haven't read the text thanks so much
lieutenant governor
let the fight go on